bei dem namen tesla denken die meisten
sicher an elektroautos mittlerweile ist
eines davon ja sogar im weltall dank
ihre maske namensgeber ist der ingenieur
nicola tesla ein absolut genialer
erfinder dass beispielsweise
wechselstrom durch unsere stromnetze
fließt das haben wir ihnen zu verdanken
keine ruhe ließen nikola tesla aber
bestimmte zahlen und zwar konkret die
ziffern 3 6 und 9
danke für diesen themen vorschlag bei
whatsapp und herzlich willkommen bei
geht es um science-fiction
ja und wie ihr euch mit mir über
whatsapp und die anderen messenger
persönlich verknüpfen können dass der
vater am ende des videos
nikola tesla wurde 856 im heutigen
kroatien geboren und gehört wohl
tatsächlich mit zu den ärzten erfindern
überhaupt und schon seine zeitgenossen
wurden immer wieder auf ein neues von
tesla beeindruckt denn er machte mit
wirklich waghalsigen experimenten auf
sich aufmerksam aus seinen händen
schossen flammen feuerbälle holten über
seinen kopf und auch millionen volt
spannung machten ihm augenscheinlich
nichts aus mandanten auch den meister
der blitze sein labor eine große scheune
beherbergte einen gigantischen
transformator mit einem durchmesser von
etwa 15 metern und einer höhe von knapp
drei metern seine schule konnte mehrere
millionen volt erzeugen mit diesem
monstrum wollte tesla beweisen dass
energie auch drahtlos übertragen werden
kann er feierte die 50 meter langen
blitze die aus dem mast schossen ganz im
gegenteil zu seinen assistenten die
große angst bekamen und genau aus diesem
grund war tesla bald auch international
als magier der elektrizität bekannt die
elektrizität war einfach seine
leidenschaft für seine erfindung
brauchte er keine modelle oder zeichnung
alles geschah mit hilfe seiner
vorstellungskraft in seinem kopf dazu
tesla einmal es ist völlig ohne
bedeutung für mich ob ich eine turbine
in meinem geist oder in der werkstatt
betreibe ich kann sogar bemerken wenn
sie aus dem gleichgewicht gerät
am ende erfand er nicht nur ein konzept
für einen wechselstrom motor sondern
entdeckte auch dessen entscheidenden
vorteil dem gleichstrom gegenüber
wechselstrom kann nahezu verlustfrei
über lange strecken durch kabel
transportiert werden mit gleichstrom ist
das nur bei kurzen strecken möglich und
teslas langfristiges ziel war
tatsächlich nicht das große kohle machen
sondern die verbreitung seiner neuen
technologie seine vision alle menschen
kostenlos und unbegrenzt mit energie
versorgen und so sagte er schon damals
in gewisser weise unsere heutige welt
voraus denn er sah stromnetze nur als
zwischenschritt zu einem komplett
kabellosen system das energie und
informationen weltweit sendet 898
entwickelt tesla dann die erste
fernbedienung und ein jahr später sendet
radiowellen erstmalig über eine distanz
von 1000 kilometern
doch neben seinen talenten hat er auch
einige tipps und marotten er hätte sich
vor der vorstellung die haare anderer
menschen zu berühren und auch frauen
ohrringe vor allem perlenohrringen
ließen ihnen erschauern
bevor er sein essen genießen konnte
musste er zunächst den kubik raum
berechnen die seine nahrung zuvor
eingenommen hatte ganz besonders
fasziniert aber war er von bestimmten
zahlen zum einen die drei seinen alltag
bestand quasi aus der 3 er wusste ich
drei mal die hände ging dreimal die
straße entlang bevor ein haus betrat und
auch andere tätigkeiten wiederholte er
so oft dass sie durch drei teilbar waren
denn auch die zahlen die man durch drei
teilen kann wie etwa die sechs oder neun
mochte er in restaurants name immer 18
servierten und in hotels musste die
zimmernummer durch drei teilbar sein
das alles hatte schon etwas zwanghaftes
und besessenes an sich tesla konnte
nicht gehen oder ohne dabei seine
schritte zu zählen in seinen arbeiten
wie ist es da immer wieder auf die
großartigen bedeutung der drei zahlen
drei sechs und neun hin
er bezeichnete sie als grundlegende
kennziffern des göttlichen mit einer
schöpferischen kraft eine seiner
aussagen dazu würdest du um die
großartigkeit der zahlen 3 6 und 9
wissen hättest du den schlüssel zum
universum noch heute gibt es theorien
nach denen diese zahlen auch als der
plan gottes bezeichnet werden andere
glauben dass diese zahlen einen vektor
der dritten und vierten dimension
repräsentieren oder der schlüssel zur
freien energie wären aber noch gibt es
dahingehend keinerlei beweise ob es also
eine reine spielerei von tesla oder
vielleicht doch ein wissenschaftlich ob
es noch einen wissenschaftlichen
hintergrund gibt vielleicht werden wir
es in zukunft erfahren wenn ihr zu den
ersten gehören wollte die es erfahren
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp wenn ihr wollt könnt euch da
auch mit telegramm instagram oder dem
facebook messenger mit mehr verknüpften
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert ihr könnt doch direkt über
mich in der redaktion von kriegst du
mitmachen und mehr zum beispiel themen
vorschlagen also wie dieses video jetzt
zum beispiel einfach hier draufklicken
und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
goodie und natürlich nicht das aber mit
der genau der glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
elektroautos revolutionäres neues
batterie konzept ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran